- Terrorism against our nation
will not stand. a a a a a a a au
11 septembre, c'est une Amérique
sous le choc qui déclare
la guerre contre le terrorisme.
Quatre mois plus tard,
jour pour jour, la base
américaine dans la baie
de
une prison extraterritoriale.
Mourad Benchellali,
ress
y a passé 30 mois. À 18 ans,
il est emmené en Afghanistan
par son grand frère, où
il sera embrigadé dans
MOURAD BENCHELLALI, médiateur
intercult., ex-détenu Guantanamo
à peine, dans ce camp
d'entraînement, omomomprends
que... que c'est bien plus grave
que ça, puisque je suis dans un
- Mourad quitte le camp
deux jours as les attentats
du World Trade Center.
Il s'enfuit vers le Pakistan,
américains.
- Je cenenends qu'il y ait
un lien direct entre l'endroit
où je suis et l'endroit
à savoir ce camp d'entraînement,
onononc, le piège se referme,
et puis surtout, je comprends
que ma petite histoire vientdede
histoire.
- Après un passage dans une
prison à Kandahar, où il sera
est transféré à Guantanamo.
- Je me retrouve incarcéré
au coeur d'une base militaire
américlaquelle je vais être prié
de mes droits et dans laquelle
je vais être détenu pendant
plusieurs mois sans aucune
statut.
- 780 prerererers, adultes
et enfants, soupçonnés
de terrorisme, seront détenu
FRAN
Amnistie internat., Canada fr.
- Le site de Guantanamo,
c'est un... c'est véritablement
un endroit de non-droit.
un Canadien. C'étaient
des enfants, et qui ont subi
des années de privation
de lib
assez épouvantables.
- 39 prisonniers sont touj
détenus à Guantanamo.
Parmi eux, 13 n'ont été
CAMILLE MARQUIS-BISSONNETTE,
doctorante, droit int., ULavalne
extraordinaire pour juger
ou pour détenir des criminels
extraordinaires. Mais je pense
oublier, c'est que peu importe
le crime, eseseseseses droits
humains qu'il faut protéger.
- Les détenus et les personnesos
comme moi étaient simplement
des personnes qui ont payé
pour les atrocités que d'autres
un endroit dans lequel
j'ai dû me rrrrrr
ne pas me radicaliser.
Et je trouve que c'est plutôt
un comble, dans une...
qui prétendait vouloir lutter
contre le terror
et donc, de fait, aussi
contre la radicalisation.
Barack Obama n'a pas pu tenir
la promesse faite en 2009
de fermer Guantanamo.
a quant à lui décidé de
maintenir ce centr
de détention en fonction.
Et l'actuel locataire de
se montre très prudent après
le retrait des troupes
américaines d'Afghanistan et
une au maintien de cette prison.
Ici Yasmine Kha
Radio-Canada, Montréa